las calles de Perú se pintaron de blanco
en Lima la capital miles de personas
salieron a las avenidas para pedir la
Paz en medio de la crisis política que
vive esa nación vestidos de blanco
ciudadanos convocados por grupos
conservadores participaron de la jornada
los vándalos
a través de la violencia por eso estamos
aquí queremos Paz No vamos a permitir
que se sigan cometiendo actos vandálicos
actos terroristas el llamado de atención
a las autoridades También estuvo
presente en la gran marcha por la paz
como se denominó la concentración Y es
que actualmente se investigan las
muertes en las manifestaciones desatadas
el mes de diciembre se contabilizan casi
dos decenas de fallecidos en
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad lo que nosotros es que ya no
haya más muertes ni por parte de la
población ni por parte de la policía
básicamente nos están condicionando que
tanto Hermanos peruanos nos estamos
matando unos con otros eso es algo que
no se puede dar cómo vamos a permitir
eso En qué mundo estamos viviendo
estamos en pleno Siglo 21 y sigue
pasando este tipo de cosas Perú vive
jornadas de inestabilidad política desde
que el expresidente Pedro Castillo
intentó disolver el congreso horas antes
de que se discutiera su permanencia como
jefe de estado Castillo fue destituido
acusado de Conspiración y rebelión las
manifestaciones de sus seguidores
provocaron que el gobierno de la
presidenta Dina boluarte declarara el
estado de emergencia se espera que al
menos diez grupos civiles y sindicatos
se retomen las protestas en el sur del
país exigirán entre otros temas la
renuncia de boluarte y la liberación de
castillo